皆さんもてないですよねモテる上で何が一番大切かまぁいろんな要素があると思うん
ですけどもまぁ
ああああこれでまあどうしようもないまあ何とかできるけどまぁどうしようもない部分
としたほかには神があったら筋肉つけたり体を細くしたりフケとかいろんな要素があっ
て人は今モテるモテないとかいろいろあると思うんですけども忘れちゃいけない大切な
要素が一つあるんですそれは何か
そう
表情で人というのは氷山一つでもうもて revo てない大きく変わってくると思う
んですよ
例えばですよ超美人の人がぐっと
柄公約はしてたら嫌でしょ美人な人ずっと扱い返してたら約ボールですよ逆にですよ逆
にすげー不細工なすげーってサイクな人仮にいたとしてもその人がすごい優しい顔で
微笑んでくれたり水分も見るだけでドキッてする中でココってしてくれたら
まあとりあえず何が言いたいかというと表情ってすごい大切なんですよねその表情作る
上で表情筋在校生する構造な周りの筋肉があるんですけども
この筋肉を鍛えることがかなりモテるためには大事なのかなと思いまして今回小皿買っ
てみました
はいブルコリストアップトレーナーぶるぶるクレカコック
泥塗る増えてなんかねこう筋肉来てるんですよねこっぺタとこう
各押す力して今何か筋肉をほぐしてくれるのかな一日三回3セットで表情が変わって
くるらしいです
なんか僕部活テレビ見たことあるんですけども氷像金って本当に大切らしくて好俺たち
が爺パ
俺たちがおじぃちゃんおばぁばんっそれでなんで俺だけがおじいちゃんおばあちゃんに
なっていくと顔の表情時に不動産を食べてくるんですよそれ
てなんかコツと老けて見えたりあるんで見えてちょっと付いたに見えたりするねあ女表
時をしっかり維持すれば若く見えるらしいです
やりましょう結構いいこと言ってると思うんですよね
いや俺を大須賀アラサーだからさなるべく幕閣いた今けどこれですね
これを押しビルでウォンウーンウーン
うん
ねん
グッ
ん
[音楽]
このシンダーで今日雑巾を鍛えるほぐすというは結果
これ本当にこんなんですよこれをそれ本当にこれで不良ずにが強くなるけど揺れる微妙
なんですけどへのすげーな電池もつかずにこれができてなかなかいいんじゃないですか
ね
をは何かそれからほんとなんか顔の筋肉がこの筋肉がなく過ぎィ
なんだこれなんだから今日税金が強くなってるってことか
[音楽]
第じゃあ何か使ってみて思ったんですけど効果はそこそこありそうな気がしますねで
これ113階3セットって書いてあるのでちょっと面倒くさい1日3回さあセットれる
のめんどくさいと思ったんでこれで3つがあって3つ一気に口につければ
人気3回3セット面の3回がなくなって1日3セットでするんじゃないかという口の
サイズ的にも多分3つぐらいが限界だと
ものでこの3つ一気につけて3セットやれば誰でもそこでもてるいい胸像をつけるんだ
と思いますそれ全然2つでやってみましょう不倒となるいけるぞ
[音楽]
そんな
名ちょっとこれやって思ったんですけども結構顔の筋肉には包んでこれはもう氷像県
絶対来てありますが
待て地でてね頑張って表情筋所にそうですよねーよ
めっちゃできたあれがめっちゃに出てきたんですけどこれをやり続ければ最強の表情筋
が付と思うので黒ちょっともうちょっと頑張ってみます
[音楽]
こうして初めは
表情筋を鍛えるために
来る子も来る日も唇に唇を重ね目
今日雑巾のトレーニングをし続け
[音楽]
うん
ん
靴ビルのこれ取れなくなっちゃったっ
[音楽]
me
uh